meanwhile the detroit lions have not won
a playoff game since 1991 30-year
anniversary congratulations detroit
lions since the last year you won a
playoff game matthew stafford first
overall pick in 2009 now gone from
detroit the new quarterback with the
rams here he is from siriusxm nfl radio
talking about the impact of the trade on
his overall approach to football
i definitely feel that way um you know
it's a new experience for my entire
family um we were so set um you know
with with our lifestyle in in uh and how
we you know kind of went about
day-to-day life in detroit that has
definitely changed and uh you know if
you don't have energy to move your wife
and four kids and a dog and everybody
out to uh california you're in a lot of
trouble so but it definitely energized
me i'm excited about the opportunity um
you know not only from uh from a family
standpoint but uh really from a football
standpoint i'm excited about you know
being a part of the you know this rams
organization that's had so much recent
success and and um i can't uh i can't
wait to get the football season going
and get all that going and at the same
time
um you know loved our time in detroit
we'll miss we'll miss that uh that city
dearly it was uh special to both me and
my family especially my wife when she
was going through some things so i love
my time in detroit but we are excited
about
you know the move to los
angeles that he is as it relates to this
move to the rams when you consider what
the rams are doing settling on cam acres
as their workhorse tailback he was very
good as a rookie had some injuries he
fought through last year had that great
thursday night game against the new
england patriots they've added to sean
jackson to complement the receiving poor
the rams offense with all those changes
led by stafford will be what chris uh
more explosive i think that's where i
look at it more than anything and i
think in all areas that's where like a
guy like stafford is going to make
everything more explosive you know one
you know like we talked about mike a
little when he first got signed or
traded there he's going to open up the
playbook for mcvay and go wait oh this
boot and this play action i used to run
these route combinations but wait now i
got a guy with a laser for a right arm i
can change these route combinations a
little bit oh this guy used to run you
know the cro the crossing route uh now
i'm going to send them on a 40-yard post
route this guy used to run the comeback
route ah the hell with that now he's
going to fake the comeback and run a you
know a 50-yard go route i think that's
where you're going to see the field open
up for the rams and not only is going to
make their passing game more explosive
because of this guy right i think it's
the other thing is it's going to make
the running game the mcvay running game
that much more dangerous you know that's
where i think he can really
slice you and dice you mcveigh's always
had the short intermediate underneath
stuff in the offense
now finally he's going to have somebody
that can scare you vertically mcveigh's
always been about i'm going to spread
you horizontally horizontally
horizontally and i'm going gonna find
little ways to once i get you spread
horizontally to find little cracks in
that seam to expose that now he's gonna
make you think about whoa the speed
sweeps the fake the speed sweeps the
fake the speed sweeps the zone runs the
play action passes and you better worry
about 50 yards down field and that's
where i think it could be fun to watch
with this rams offense this year
i'm curious to see how stafford thrives
or doesn't in the offense curious to see
chris how
the offensive line is able to buy him
enough time because that's a key
ingredient to this he's not exactly a
guy who's going to be sprinting out of
trouble and moving around a lot yes he
can make the throw down the field yes
he's a tough guy who's going to stand in
there but you still need to give him
some time to set up and find whoever it
is that's open but
there's definitely a step up from jared
goff
to matthew stafford no dan
in in the toughest division in football
i think the rams become a much tougher
team to beat by boosting that offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports